hey schönen guten abend zu zdf heute
live schön dass ihr bei uns im stream
zeit der tod von queen elizabeth der
zweite hat gestern abend millionen
menschen in großbritannien und auf der
ganzen welt erschüttert 70 jahre lang
war sie die königin und hier haben wir
auch bilder von heute die die trauer
sehr briefen zeigt viele legen
blumensträuße am buckingham palace
wieder zünden kerzen an um der queen und
ihrem lebenswerk zu gedenken und auch
ein bisschen die eigene trauer über den
tod natürlich auszudrücken auch in
belval dem schottischen landsitz der
rolls dort ist ja es wird die zweite
gestern verstorben legen auch tausende
blumen nieder trauern
gerade angesprochen 70 jahre und 200 14
tage war queen elizabeth die zweite
königin jetzt aber der wechsel eine neue
ära zu könig charles den dritten und
julia melchior ist bei uns im studio
königshaus experten schönen guten abend
oder wir sprechen gleich über seinen
ersten tag und was auch von seiner rede
die wir gleich werden auch noch zu
erwarten ist
vorher möchte ich euch oder aber auch
gemeinsam zeigen und so ein bisschen in
die stimmung rein gehen da können wir
auch gemeinsam auf einen tweet schon der
durchs netz gegangen ist ich mache das
jemals für euch auf schaut mal am
buckingham palace
auf der einen seite die trauernden
menschen
fahnen auf halbmast haben wir gehört und
auf der anderen seite das sehen wir
jetzt eben ein regenbogen und das
beschreibt glaube ich so ein bisschen
auch die allgemeine gefühlslage da in
großbritannien ein zwiespältiges bild
von
melchior wir sehen gleich natürlich auch
die erste rede von könig charles dem
dritten es ist eine aufgezeichnete rede
und er wird dann zur nation sprechen
seine erste rede was erwartest du von
dieser rede also ich glaube noch nicht
dass es jetzt eine bahnbrechende und
richtungsweisende rede sein wird sondern
es geht sicherlich darum dass er auch
noch mal seiner mutter tribut zollt und
sich an die nation wendet diese ja auch
wie diese trauer mit der familie teilt
und aber vielleicht wird er auch schon
so ein kleines gefühl geben dafür was
von ihm zu erwarten ist er ist ja sehr
empfänglich so für die themen der zeit
und ich glaube auch das ist etwas was
wir von charles sicherlich erwarten
werden erstmal einen sanften übergang
aber wahrscheinlich doch etwas klarere
positionierung zu den strömungen der
zeit also ich sag jetzt mal das thema
umwelt und nachhaltigkeit einerseits
aber auch weil er halt auch in der
vergangenheit schon jetzt mal gesprochen
hat über die koloniale vergangenheit von
großbritannien und auch die schuld die
großbritannien auf sich oder auf sich
nehmen muss in der kolonialen
vergangenheit im mit blick auf sklaverei
oder so also er wird sicherlich da die
tür auch ein stück weit aufstoßen ja
absolut wir sprechen natürlich gleich
auch mit dir weiter und wenn ihr auch
noch fragen habt an julia und auch gern
der welt stellt die gerne in die chats
oder per mail an zdf heute - live at
zdf.de hier im hintergrund sehen wir
gerade bilder auch vom parallel
laufenden gedenkgottesdienst da können
wir zusammen draufschauen an das st
paul's cathedral
der findet ohne die royale familie statt
und da werden wir auch im weiteren
verlauf des teams immer wieder mal
hinschauen julia aber ganz kurz wenn wir
diese stimmungen sehen auf der einen
seite der gedenkgottesdienst und auf der
anderen seite die trauer über den tod
der queen und aber auch da gleichzeitig
der erste tag von könig charles den
dritten du hast ein paar themen
angesprochen wie schwierig ist dieser
moment für ihn persönlich jetzt auch
gleich diese diese rede die hat er schon
gehalten aber generell diese rede zu
formulieren gut ist er war ja jetzt sehr
lange darauf vorbereitet also nicht nur
weil er der am längsten amtierende
thronfolger in der geschichtsschreibung
überhaupt ist sondern auch weil in den
letzten jahren die königin zunehmend
schwächer geworden ist und sich rück
zurückgezogen hat also insofern man
musste schon damit rechnen dass der tag
näher rückt irgendwie hat es jeder
verdrängt aber charles ist das natürlich
völlig präsent gewesen und er hat ja
auch die königin in den letzten jahren
zunehmend auch vertreten und es ist für
ihn jetzt nicht so dass er von heute auf
morgen ins kalte wasser geschmissen wird
überhaupt nicht und er ist ja nun auch
eine gestandene persönlichkeit mit 73
jahren macht er jetzt quasi den karriere
der sprung während andere halt jetzt
irgendwie schon den rat erst jedes
rentenalter genießen aber
ich glaube dass es eine monarchie immer
schlimm ist das ist aber halt auch so
das wesen der monarchie der erbmonarchie
der könig ist tot es lebe der könig oder
die königin in diesem fall ist tot es
lebe der könig also für ein
thronfolger ist es immer traurig der tag
wenn sein großer tag kommt weil das
bedeutet also in der regel dass der
vater oder die mutter in diesem fall
halt gestorben ist ja absolut große
anteilnahme in der britischen
bevölkerung in der ganzen welt neun von
zehn menschen so schreibt es die
washington post post kennen kein leben
ohne die queen das liest man eine enorm
krasse zahl was hat das so für eine
bedeutung dieses dieses diese sache auch
für die zukunft
es ist eine zäsur in der geschichte
die königin hat ja einfach auch einen
großen beitrag geleistet für den für das
miteinander der nationen präsident obama
hatte anlässlich ihres 70 thronjubiläums
neulich gesagt dass die königin die welt
ein stück sicherer gemacht hat weil sie
der stabilitätsfaktor war einer der
bedeutendsten demokratien der welt und
durch ihren einfluss sie hat stabilität
gegeben und gestand für kontinuität und
hat also auch diesen ganzen ups and
downs in der geschichte also stand
gehalten dass das doch ein großer
verlust ist
aber man darf auch nicht vergessen dass
die königin auch nicht immer nur populär
war also es gab ja auch die sechziger
und siebziger jahre wo das königshaus
und diese queen sehr hinterfragt worden
sind also insofern das müssen wir auch
immer ist bewegt sich in
wellenbewegungen aber sie weiß auf dem
gipfel natürlich ihrer amtszeit ein
schweres erbe auch für könig charles dem
das war mehr als ein versprechen
tiefe
persönlich verpflichtung die ihr ganzes
leben definierte sie hat opfer auf sich
genommen für ihre pflicht
ihre hingabe
als monarchin
bundy geschwächt in zeiten der
veränderungen des fortschrittes in
zeiten der freude und der feiern und in
zeiten der traurigkeit und des verlustes
in die mit ihrem leben
sie die tradition max klein gehalten und
gleichzeitig sich dem fortschritt
verpflichtet gefühlt und das macht uns
ja große als nation für die zuneigung
bewunderung und respekt
der ihr entgegengebracht wurden wahlen
scanners reichmann ihrer regentschaft
und jedes mitglied meiner familie kann
bezeugen dass sie diese qualitäten mit
wärme humor
und einer
klaren fähigkeit verband das beste im
menschen zu sehen ich würdige das
andenken meiner mutter und ich ehre ihr
leben des dienstes
ich weiß dass ihr tod große trauer über
so viele menschen muss er ihnen bringt
und ich teile dieses gefühl des
verlustes mit ihnen allen gilt
als die königin inthronisiert wurde
kämpft in großbritannien und die welt
sie immer noch mit dem leid und den
folgen des zweiten weltkrieges
und mann lebte immer noch nach den
konventionen früherer zeiten
im laufe der letzten 60 jahre gesehen
dass unsere gesellschaft eine von vielen
kulturen und eine von vielen religiösen
glaubensrichtungen wurden die
institutionen des staates haben sich
auch verändert aber durch all diese
veränderungen und herausforderungen
hindurch war es so dass
unsere nation ski und die größte familie
unserer nationen auf deren erreichte
sich so stolz bin hat sich
weiterentwickelt hin zu wohlstand ist
aufgeblüht aber unsere werte sind
weiterhin konstant geblieben und das
muss auch so bleiben
die rolle und die pflichten
wie auch die besondere
verantwortung das märchen
gegenüberstellen kirche von england
und mein eigener glaube ist so
verwurzelt in dieser herrlichen in
diesem glauben und den werten
dieser glaube hervorbringt bin ich auch
dazu erzogen worden anderen zu schienen
und ich respektiere sehr stark schrieb
richtigen tradition im zweier ist und
verantwortlichkeit unserer einzigartigen
geschichte und unseres parlamentarischen
system die
königin selbst hat sich diesem gedanken
hingeben
verpflichte mich auch während der zeit
die mir gott noch geben machten
konstitutionellen prinzipien aufrecht zu
halten und die grundlage unserer nation
sind wo immer sie leben im vereinigten
königreich oder
territorien oder hand geburten eben
überall auf der welt und aus welchem
hintergrund oder welcher
glaubensrichtung sie auch kommen mögen
bild ich ihnen dienen mit loyalität und
respekt und liebe wie ich das auch in
meinem leben getan habe mein leben wird
sich natürlich verändert
nun da ich meine neuen ich würde meine
neue ausrichtung auf mich nehme es geht
nicht mehr möglich sein für mich so viel
zeit und energie
an die
wohlfahrtsorganisation zu geben ein uns
ins rotenburger themen die mir immer so
wichtig war aber ich weiß dass diese
wichtige arbeit weitergeführt wird in
den
fertigen hessen anderer
auch meine familie verändert sich ich
freue mich darauf mich auf die hilfe
meiner lieben frau camilla rechnen darf
seit
jahren geheiratet haben
geworden
sie wird eine
richtung und hingabe an die hand mit
geringen auflagen verlassen
die schottischen titel übernehmen die
hier so wichtig waren er folgt mir als
herzog von korn und er übernehme die
verantwortung für das herzogtum und
korngold die ich über fünf jahrzehnte er
hatte
heute freue ich mich ihn zum trends von
wales zu machen
das ist ein land dessen tätig innehaben
my life durfte und das war ein privileg
für mich während meines ergebnis fiel
mit kathrin an seiner seite werden der
neue prinzessin von wales compensation
unsere nationalen ausspreche inspirieren
würden sie werden die ränder in die
mitte bringen wo wichtige heerführers
express gemacht werden und ich möchte
meine liebe für herren ecken auswirken
während sie weiterhin ihr leben in
übersee aufbauen in der little blue
wings time und etwas mehr als einer
woche werden wir als nation wieder
zusammengekommen als carmen wolf und
auch als globale gemeinschaft
um meine geliebte mutter zu beerdigen
und in unsere trauer sagt wir daran
denken und stärkeres in welches licht
sie in die welt brachte im namen meiner
ganzen familie kann ich habe meine tiefe
gefühle des dankes für ihn boot wäre
beileidsbekundungen und ihre
unterstützung ausdrücken sie bedeuten ja
ist er sehr viel mehr als ich sagen
können und meiner lieben mutter möchte
ich sagen du
letzte große reise beginnt um meinen
verstorbenen vater wieder zu trinken
möchte ich eine sache danke danke für
deine liebe und für deine hingabe für
unsere familie und die familie der
nationen der duh ist so gut gedient hast
während all dieser jahre
fleisches mögen
bengel dich zur besten
also eine tief bewegende rede erste rede
von könig charles dem dritten die wir
gerade gehört haben sorry ganz kurz dass
die übersetzung etwas zu spät angefangen
hat aber vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz
zusammenfassen also könig charles hat es
angesprochen hat seiner mutter gerade
zum schluss nochmal für ihre liebe die
sie ihm gegenüber gezeigt hat der
familie und auch der ganzen nation zum
ausdruck gebracht und sich selber er hat
die verpflichtung angesprochen die die
sie damit auf sich genommen hat und er
selber hat auch gesagt dass er eben
diese verpflichtung selber auch antreten
möchte und dem ja ganz großbritannien
und der ganzen familie eben genauso
dienen möchte wie es seine mutter getan
hat julia du hast mit uns die rede auch
verfolgt passt passen diese worte zu dem
charakter wie du charles auch in den
ganzen jahren so beobachtet das passt
diese art der ansprache zu ihm der
mutter so zu danken und sich ja in den
dienst auch zu stellen und der absolut
des der wappen spruch des prince of
wales lautet ich die ihn und er war der
prinz of wales und hat danach gelebt er
hat der seiner mutter gedient das war
seine chefin das staatsoberhaupt er hat
dem land gedient und der krone gedient
und das ist das was ich halt auch
erwarte ist eben dieser sanfte übergang
aus dem zeitalter von königin elizabeth
der zweite jetzt zu könig charles dem
dritten und da entspricht dann natürlich
genau eigentlich auch den erwartungen
und ich glaube auch so werden sich also
auch die briten sicherlich bald wohl
fühlen und verstanden fühlen er hat ich
kann auch diesen moment halt auch heute
schon wie man ihn sah von buckingham
palast und erst auf die menschen
zugegangen und hat hände geschüttelt es
ist einfach dieses dieser dieses zeichen
von sympathie und
zu den menschen das ist doch etwas was
charles und camilla zusammen beherrschen
vielen dank julia melchior für deine
einschätzung hier bei uns im studio bei
zdf heute live und eben diesen ausblick
was das mit der bevölkerung macht
darüber sprechen wir natürlich auch im
weiteren verlauf des streams bleiben
jetzt aber auch noch mal bei der
persönlichkeit könig charles der dritte
er hat gerade schon ein bisschen was
davon gezeigt aber andreas stamm hat
noch mehr ein ausführliches und
spannendes porträt zu ihm
der trauernde könig auf dem weg nach
london ins zentrum der macht des
vereinigten königreichs es warten die
offizielle proklamation die letzten
vorbereitungen für den abschied von
seiner mutter charles der dritte
übernimmt die volle kontrolle
der letzte schritt eines lange geplanten
stabwechsels jahrelang schon übernahm
charles immer mehr aufgaben seiner
mutter die parlamentseröffnung etwa
einer der bedeutendsten termine des
monarchen
hat jede menge zeit gehabt zu verstehen
was auf ihn zukommt schon vor über einem
jahrzehnt dass die königin begonnen die
verfassungsmäßige macht rechte und
pflichten mit ihm zuteil
seine lehrjahre verbringt charles vor
allem mit dem thema umweltschutz ein
mahner der allerersten stunde ass bringt
ihm viel spott ein nicht jeder satz
jeder werbespot für die belange der
natur sitzt
[Musik]
juni wird erwachsen werden so die
reaktion damals aber er blickt dabei und
aus einem als exzentrisch beschriebenen
wesenszug wurde eine positive
besessenheit die heute eine art global
akzeptierte glaubenslehre ist
als umwelt könig würde charles wohl
gerne in die geschichte eingehen doch es
droht ungemach kann er das vereinigte
königreich zusammen halten vor allem die
nach unabhängigkeit strebenden schotten
holding in das königreich bewahren kann
keine person allein es ist ein sehr
politisiert es fällt und in politisches
darf er sich als könig nicht wirklich
einmischen aber er wird sich sehr darum
kümmern
das commonwealth der lose staatenbund
überbleibsel des empire in 15
mitgliedsländern ist der britische
monarch sogar noch staatsoberhaupt als
barbados die republik ausruft ist
charles als vertreter der queen dabei
einen vorgeschmack munkeln manche ist er
der totengräber der monarchie
für was brauchen wir das königshaus für
was steht entsteht es noch für eine
gesamt britische identität warum ein
privileg das vererbt wird anerkennen
daraus können große probleme erwachsen
viele fragen die regentschaft seiner
mutter war geprägt von stabilität
eine ära in unruhigen zeiten
die war nun auch auf könig charles den
dritten
andreas staben mit einem porträt zu king
charles dem dritten was dazu auch noch
passt dann zeige ich euch ganz kurz auch
noch mal hier bei mir auf dem bildschirm
die new york times hat hier aufgemacht
mit einer zeile once in a self dauerte
in youngman die kamps tour de france
seventy freezers fsj gray hat eminems
und ich glaube treffen da kann man es
dann fast nicht zusammenfassen von der
new york times und auch ihr habt im chat
immer wieder auch viele positive
meldungen für das erbe aber natürlich
auch noch mal viele trauerbekundungen
zum tode von queen elizabeth der zweite
zum beispiel bm uci schreibt in seiner
tiefen trauer das bezieht sich jetzt
noch einmal auf charles eine rede zu
halten die wir vorhin gehört haben das
kostet so glaubt sie schon sehr viel
disziplin und überwindung und dann auch
noch mal der wunsch dem neuen könig viel
glück da es sicher nicht einfach haben
wird ja wichtiger punkt den die userin
bei facebook da anspricht und den
vertiefen wir jetzt hier bei zdf heute
live mit einer weiteren
gesprächspartnerinnen das ist tanja bild
man wir gehen da jetzt noch mal ins
detail schönen guten abend vorbild man
wir sehen sie da gerade schon danke für
ihre zeit sehr gerne als ich habe gerade
angesprochen wir wollen noch mal ins
detail gehen was die stimmung in der
britischen bevölkerung betrifft und was
ist vielleicht auch braucht gerade
angesprochen von der userin damit die
monarchie sozusagen auch gefestigt wird
ganz kurz noch mal zu ihnen dass sie
haben auch eine interessante geschichte
sie lehren aktuell in glasgow geschichte
kommen aber ursprünglich aus bielefeld
so und dann haben sie gesagt anfang der
90er sind sie mit ihrer großmutter nach
schottland gereist und haben sich dann
zitat so sehr in dieses land verliebt
und zwar so sehr dass sie dann
deutschland verlassen haben und jetzt in
großbritannien sich niedergelassen haben
frau bild man erstmal was macht es für
sie so besonders und wie erleben sie
gerade auch die stimmung in diesem land
das sie so sehr lieben nach diesem
ereignis
also vor allen dingen ist das natürlich
einfach mal eigentlich eine schockstarre
das ist das beste wort glaube ich was
man benutzen kann und egal ob man jetzt
von der monarchie besonders viel hält
oder auch nicht ist das glaube ich für
die meisten männer hier so die queen war
halt immer da und das war glaube ich
sogar auch aus deutscher perspektive für
viele menschen so ich habe gestern ein
paar deutsche touristen gesehen die
zufälligerweise in bern wo die queen
verstarb auf ihrer reise unterwegs waren
und die dazu befragt wurden also das ist
glaube ich vor allen dingen auch dass
das haupt gefühl im moment wie geht man
damit um wenn jemand der immer da ist
auf einmal nicht mehr da ist und es ist
nun hier das staatsoberhaupt da hat das
weitreichende folgen noch aber das ist
wirklich glaube ich das gefühl dass sie
überall sehen und was auch raus kommt
ganz stark ist auf jeden fall auf
sozialen medien dass viele menschen
sagen ich hab gar nicht erwartet dass
ich so emotional bin finde es aber und
das fand ich auch sehr interessant und
ich glaube das hängt damit auch
insbesondere zusammen dass man eben
ebenso eine konstante verloren hat ja
emotionen die sie gerade ansprechen wir
sprechen den weiteren verlauf des
streams mit ihnen weiter frau bültmann
gehen jetzt aber nochmal wir drüber zu
unserem korrespondenten vor ort in
london am buckingham palace und das ist
andreas stamm andreas größte ich erst
mal herzlich willkommen bei uns im
stream wir haben vorhin auch schon das
porträt von dir gesehen was du zu
charles gemacht hast aber vielleicht die
frage an dich wie erlebst du gerade die
stimmung bei dir großbritannien zwischen
trauer und neuer
es ist vor allen dingen natürlich
geprägt von der trauer allerdings heute
der emotionale höhepunkt keine frage als
prinz charles nein könig charles man
muss sich wirklich daran gewöhnen man
hat ihn so lange als kunst bezeichnet er
hier heute in london zurück kam der
rolls standard ab ging auf dem
buckingham palast die flagge des königs
und er dann ein bad in der menge nahm
man kann das was zu sagen natürlich im
rahmen der trauer es war sehr emotional
er war sehr gerührt es gab sogar ein
küsschen auf die wange als erhard
volksnähe gesucht und hat die atoss und
trauer spenden wollen aber auch trost
und trauer bekommen von den menschen
denn es ist ja auch immerhin seine
mutter die starb und eben gab es dann
noch die große rede an die nation und
das war auch noch mal
ein dickes ding muss man sagen denn
damit hat er seine regentschaft jetzt
erstmal definiert ja absolut ich muss
das selber auch zu geben das ging hier
schon auch im studio absolut unter die
haut an sehr berührend wir haben auch
die bilder gesehen von vom vorabend wo
auch viele menschen um sich herum hin
gepilgert sind gestern um der queen auch
nochmal zu gedenken viele kerzen
ja und jetzt auch gerade der
gedenkgottesdienst der parallel läuft in
saint paul's cathedral
vielleicht skizzieren wir da ganz kurz
den ablauf und auch die nächsten
schritte des protokolls in den nächsten
tagen
also wie sehen die nächsten tage aus wie
bei andreas laut protokoll
auch mal ich glaube das muss man noch
mal unterstreichen denn das war etwas
ganz besonderes denn es ist die queen
hatte fünf solcher ansprache an die
nation in 70 jahren und das war die
erste und einer der wenigen die prinz
könig charles haben wird und merkt es
definiert und vor allen dingen darüber
das ist ein tribut an seine mutter war
warmherzig tief und es ging kaum um ihn
es ging um seine mutter und ich glaube
damit hat er den nagel auf den kopf
getroffen denn die stimmung hier ist am
tag nach dem tod der ewigen königin
quasi dass es um sie geht und nicht um
ihn und das er hat kontinuität
versprochen er hat etwas wiederholt was
die queen 1947 erklärt hat nämlich dass
sie immer pflicht und pflichterfüllung
im dienste des landes ganz nach vorne
stellen wird hat will also kontinuität
wahren und er hat auch klar gemacht es
geht um eine übergangs königtum das muss
man so sagen hat erklärt er hat nicht
mehr so viele jahre hat über prinz
william und catherine also die nächste
generation gesprochen die er sehr
schnell heran führen wird und ich glaube
das markiert eben er versucht und großen
fußstapfen auszufüllen weiß dass das
natürlich in so kurzer zeit fast
unmöglich ist und präsentiert sich somit
ein bisschen als einer der das feld
bereitet dann für die nächste generation
der rolls eben dann können es william
und prinzessin catherine
danke dafür eine analyse was sagen dir
menschen die du heute getroffen hast
30 gerade
dazu kommen wir gleich später andreas du
bist noch bei uns vielen dank ich wollte
ich gerade fragen was dir die menschen
am buckingham palace zu dieser
stimmungslage zu diesen ereignissen
sagen was hörst du das
ding natürlich so langsam einen dass
eine person die 85 prozent der briten
immer als ihre königin wahrgenommen
haben und niemand anders dass die jetzt
nicht mehr da es ist eine andere
stimmung sagen auch viele wie damals bei
princess dajana als die stadt das war
eine tragödie dass waren drama ein
unfall natürlich war den leuten bewusst
eine 96-jährige die ist näher am tod als
am leben und das ist eben jetzt passiert
aber es ist dieses tiefe gefühl der
verbundenheit dass da eine konstante
geht eine konstante die großbritannien
dieses vereinigte königreich 70 jahre
lang irgendwie zusammengehalten hat
überparteilich sie war unglaublich
beliebt sie ist durch große krisen
gegangen durch große tragödien aber sie
hat dieses land zusammengehalten von den
anfängen ihrer regentschaft als das
empire abgewickelt wurde winston
churchill da war über brad pitt über
terror über den kalten krieg über corona
auf wo sie noch mal ganz groß der einen
de facto war und auch viel trost
gespendet hat in dieser dunklen zeit mit
vielen lockdown und ich glaube das ist
die stimmung die hier viele zehn mal
mehr und mal weniger blumigen worten
rüberbringen andreas abschließende frage
an dich bleiben wird dann weil du es
auch gerade angesprochen hast noch mal
bei krise trifft der zweiten von gundi
abramsky kommt bei facebook auch noch
mal viel kraft für die zukunft
rest in peace
wie ist sozusagen der plan in den
nächsten tagen auch hinsichtlich ihrer
beerdigung
die queen wird ja noch aufgebaut im
ballsaal auf schloss balmoral
übermorgen geht es dann auf die reise
nach dem run der sagt dort wird sie im
hollywood palace ankommen das ist ihr
pallas in der schottischen hauptstadt
und dann auch eine große
gedenkgottesdienstes charles kathedrale
dort werden dann sozusagen die schotten
abschied nehmen können und dann wird es
einen tag später zurück nach london dann
wird sie aufgebaut im parlamentsgebäude
im westminster palace in westminster
hall dort dann das kondolenzbuch dort
werden dann natürlich hunderttausende
möglicherweise sich von ihr
verabschieden und dann zehn tage nach
ihrem ableben oder von heute gerechnet
soll es dann das große starts die großen
stars bei setzung geben mit einem großen
gedenkgottesdienst in westminster abbey
und dann nochmal einer prozession von
hier london ins etwas außerhalb
gelegenen schloss windsor und dort wird
sie dann freigesetzt werden in der sun
george's chapel das ist die
familiengruft dort und dann eben neben
ihren ehemann philip dass die 73 jahre
durch dieses leben als queen begleitet
hat an ihrer seite und ich danke dir
sehr sehr herzlich für diese
detaillierten information und auch für
diese bewegende eindrücke die du uns da
geschildert dass vielen dank
eine der großen fragen die sich
trotz der trauer trotz der neuen ära
natürlich vielleicht auch irgendwo schon
im hinterkopf stellt ist die frage wie
geht es jetzt nach dem tod auch mit der
britischen monarchie unter charles dem
dritten weiter und wir schauen da mal
gemeinsam darauf wie die briten generell
gerade zu ihrem königshaus stehen da
fällt auf die zustimmung allgemein in
der bevölkerung die ist eigentlich noch
recht hoch 62 prozent sagen ja wir sind
für die monarchie 22 sind nur dagegen
bei den 18 bis 24 jährigen zeigt sich
dann schon die fußes bilder sagen nur
noch 33 prozent jahren wollen wir 31
prozent sind da schon kritischer das
zeigt natürlich so ein bisschen mit
blick auf die zukunft wie sich das
entwickeln wird denn ja da ist auch
nämlich der verlauf zu erkennen dass da
die zustimmung über die jahre auch
abgenommen hat also was sagt das eben
aus darüber sprechen wir jetzt nochmal
über die perspektive der jugend mit
tanja bild man die haben wir vorhin
schon mal eingeführt lebt mittlerweile
in glasgow in schottland gebürtige
bielefelderin und kann uns natürlich
jetzt noch mal genau diese thematik
erklären schönen guten abend erstmal
noch mal frau bültmann wir haben gerade
die zahlen gesehen wie erklären sie sich
dass das die allgemeine bevölkerung
zufriedener auf die monarchie blickt
aber die junge generation sagt sind wir
irgendwie so ein bisschen skeptisch
also ich kann das natürlich letztendlich
auch nur vermuten ich hatte vorhin noch
mal auf sozialen medien geschaut ob da
heute schon so diskutiert wird und ich
denke das hat viel damit zu tun welche
relevanz eben die monarchie im
alltäglichen leben für menschen hat und
wie man das als bezugspunkt sieht in
vielerlei hinsicht haben wir alle diesen
bezugspunkt ziemlich stark ich habe eben
noch mal meinen pass rausgeholt ich bin
nämlich auch briten jetzt und wenn ich
dir jetzt mal auch klappen würde was ich
mache weil sofort da meine nummer steht
aber das geht da auch etwas über die
queen darüber zum beispiel also selbst
ich und alle lieben pass haben haben
diese bezüge im täglichen leben da
glaube ich ist dann aber auch zu
erkennen warum vielleicht junge menschen
den bezug manchmal da nicht sehen weil
man andere dinge macht und andere
interessen hat was ich interessant finde
ist ob tatsächlich das wurde eben schon
in einem bericht angesprochen dieser
umwelt könig das vielleicht ein bisschen
verschieben könnte der klimawandel ist
natürlich ein ganz großes thema auch für
uns hier wo ich wohne und wenn ich das
einmal korrigieren darf ich wohne in
edinburgh obwohl ich in glasgow arbeitet
das ist schon richtig wohne in albstadt
hier der vielleicht mal irgendwann unter
wasser stehen wird und könig charles ist
schon jemand der sich also wirklich sehr
damit auseinandergesetzt hat also ist da
vielleicht auch wirklich noch durchaus
eurem raum zur bewegung da aber im
moment ist natürlich vor allen dingen
wirklich die trauer und diese
schockstarre von der ich eben sprach
auch im vordergrund
so wie ja auf jeden fall ein problem sie
sprechen aber den wichtigen aspekt an
könig charles der dritte haben sie
gesagt hat in den vergangenen wochen
monaten jahren auch diese zwei aspekte
in den vordergrund gestellt natürlich
eines der drängenden und wichtigsten
themen auch für die zukunft von uns
allen was würden sie sagen wird er das
auch in seiner regentschaft jetzt weiter
durchziehen wird das im fokus seien
also theoretisch würde ich jetzt erstmal
sagen müssen wahrscheinlich eher nicht
weil er ja nicht unbedingt politisch
sein soll ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich hoffe er wird das tun auch deshalb
weil die regierung die wir jetzt haben
da leider vielleicht nicht die größe
tollsten voraussetzungen hat und
vielleicht kann er da eine korrektur
sozusagen bieten aber vielleicht ist
hier auch noch ein guter punkt um noch
mal etwas anderes zu sagen und zwar geht
es ja hier nicht nur um großbritannien
und das vereinigte königreich sondern
auch um das kongress und die anderen
länder wo könig charles auch jetzt head
of state dann sein wird und viele von
diesen ländern viele im commonwealth
sind ja besonders bedroht vom
klimawandel und da ist es vielleicht
auch wirklich wichtig dass nochmal jetzt
zu sagen dass da ein anknüpfungspunkt
ist und das ist auch glaube ich deshalb
besonders wichtig weil ich es
problematisch sehe auch gerade aus
dieser jüngeren perspektive wenn wir das
ganze nur aus unserer europäischen aus
unserem europäischen blickwinkel
betrachten es gibt eben noch viele
andere länder wieder auch betroffen sind
und die haben das wissen wir ja schon
durchaus einen ganz anderen blick auf
diese fragen
ja absolut
und eine weitere frage die sich
natürlich stellt wenn charles sozusagen
auch den klima aspekt in den vordergrund
stellt ist das schon mal ein wichtiger
baustein und natürlich auch die jüngere
generation anzusprechen aber eigentlich
natürlich auch einen beitrag zu leisten
für uns alle was glauben sie ist darüber
hinaus noch wichtig um die 18 bis 24
jährigen zu überzeugen mehr zu packen
denn dann muss ich einmal nachfragen
mehr zu packen damit meinst du damit
meine ich einfach zu überzeugen dass man
sagt ja ja ist die monarchie eben doch
etwas ist was auch der jüngeren
generation etwas bringt also vielleicht
muss man da etwas weiter ausholen
großbritannien das war eigentlich ein
königreich ist natürlich zu diesem
zeitpunkt an einem wirklich seltsam
schneide punkt zum einen weil eben queen
elizabeth verstorben ist aber natürlich
auch alles was schon die jahre vorher
passiert ist und es ist leider eine
tatsache dass für die junge generation
von briten es heute wesentlich weniger
möglichkeiten im leben gibt als das noch
vor ein paar jahren der fall war das
hängt sich am brett auf das hat
natürlich mit der monarchie an sich
nichts zu tun aber die monarchie und das
hat ja zb auch emanuel makro zum tod der
queen gesagt hat ja schon immer brücken
gebaut und da ist vielleicht auch noch
mal ein punkt wo gerade für jüngere
briten der könig eine rolle spielen
könnte
passend dazu habt ihr auch immer wieder
kommentare für uns im chat vielen dank
dafür
da kommt auch eben darüber wo wir auch
gerade schon gesprochen haben immer
wieder auch der klimaaspekte rosemarie
klemm steht schreibt bei facebook ich
glaube er wird ein guter könig er ist
friedlich und emotional ist
umweltbewusst und menschlich darüber
haben wir gesprochen auch gabriele münch
schreibt uns man sollte ihm eine chance
geben sich zu beweisen viel glück frau
bild man was hören sie so aus ihrem
umfeld da
diese chance wird die von den briten
auch gemacht es gibt ja eigentlich
umfragen die zeigen dass er bisher noch
nicht ganz so beliebt war
also ich will der frage wirklich nicht
ausreichen aber ich glaube das problem
ist etwas anderes und zwar dass
großbritannien ganz ganz viele probleme
im moment hat natürlich zum einen solche
die andere wie auch deutschland auch
haben die energiekrise wir haben alle
ihr also natürlich den den krieg in der
ukraine im blick auch und was
schreckliches dort passiert aber und ich
will das wirklich nicht unbedingt
nochmal immer darauf bringen aber der
brh exit hat hier viel zerrüttet auf
eine art und weise die sich wirklich
sozusagen ihnen das gewebe der
gesellschaft durch gefressen hat und ich
glaube dass es deshalb vielleicht noch
mal schwieriger sein wird die leute mehr
wieder zusammenzubringen nicht weil des
königs charles ist sondern einfach weil
die ausgangssituation sehr sehr
schwierig ist und das ist aber etwas was
mir insgesamt sehr viel sorgen macht
aber das habe ich heute dazu auch sehr
oft gehört von menschen das eben jetzt
auch wieder durch das wegfallen dieser
konstanten der queen die stabilität
vielleicht auch noch einmal mehr ins
wanken gerät aber und wenn ich das
einmal noch zitieren darf ein journalist
schon noch gefehlt hat sehr gut
geschrieben fand ich ein teil unserer
kollektiven unseres kollektiven leben es
ist nun einfach nicht mehr da
ja danke dass du dieses zitat teilen und
auch so ein bisschen einblicke in die
sorgen geben wir hören jetzt auch noch
mal rein in reaktionen vielleicht auch
sorgen eben von jüngeren menschen die
sich auch am buckingham palace heute
aufgehalten haben
es wird interessant sein wie charles mit
der situation umgeht er ist nun der
nächste nach einer solch langen zeit
ehrlich gesagt muss man abwarten ob er
die gleiche stabilität mitbringt wie
queen alles oder in den vergangenen
jahren
generation wir sind weniger monarchisten
und mehr fans von queen elizabeth
persönlich nun hat charles sehr große
fußstapfen und bei den ganzen krisen der
pandemie der energiekrise das sind
schwierige themen und ich hoffe dass er
einen guten job macht bei der
repräsentation unseres landes
ja also da und noch mal die hoffnung
groß und es passt ja auch so ein
bisschen zu den themen die wir gerade
besprochen haben frau bild man sie haben
gerade schon ausblick gegeben auf ganz
großbritannien auf das commonwealth und
eben auch auf die zukunft und die rolle
der monarchie ich weiß das ist jetzt
gerade wirklich sehr ad hoc und sehr
schwierig aber weil sie es gerade schon
mal ein bisschen an gerissen haben was
glauben sie denn wie werden die nächsten
monate
wochen vielleicht erstmal oder auch
jahre dann aussehen kann man das schon
sagen
also ich bin herr historikerin ich gucke
in die vergangenheit und eigentlich
nicht in die zukunft und es wäre ja von
mir ziemlich anmaßend das jetzt
irgendwie voraussagen zu wollen aber die
tatsache ist dass wir in einer
schwierigen lage hier sind und ich
befürchte dass die jetzige regierung
nicht unbedingt helfen wir da die wogen
zu glätten da könnte man zum beispiel
mal auf das problem der sich auf die
problematik der situation in nordirland
blicken die minister die da gerade für
einberufen worden sind nun sozusagen die
hardliner der hardliner und dann muss
man sich fragen warum tut man so was
wenn doch sowieso schon alles ziemlich
zerrüttet ist und da hoffe ich wirklich
wieder auch dass könig charles das also
auch tatsächlich erkennt und dann eben
wie seine mutter ist eigentlich getan
hat versucht also ein bisschen gegen zu
werden dafür ist ja das königshaus auch
irgendwie da und vielleicht in gewisser
weise besser positioniert als ein
gewähltes staatsoberhaupt das weiß ich
nicht aber manchmal denke ich dass aber
das bezieht sich eben auch auf die lange
regierungsseite der ehemaligen nun
verstorbenen königin ja aber also von
daher als antwort etwas ausweichend
vielleicht aber ich bin da jetzt nicht
besonders positiv das muss ich ehrlich
sagen
aber trotzdem haben sie gerade auch und
haben wir ja vielleicht auch
konstruktive ansätze für die rolle der
monarchie gerade besprochen klimaaspekte
die haben wir gerade heraus gearbeitet
die ja vielleicht die die einschätzung
die sie haben oder das negative bild in
zukunft ja vielleicht doch etwas
verbessern vielen dank tanja bild man
für ihre einschätzungen dass sie sowohl
den zwiespalt zwischen der rolle der
monarchie aber auch der politischen
herausforderungen da noch einmal
aufgezeigt haben uns das klar aufgezeigt
haben und analysiert haben herzlichen
dank dafür und schöne grüße nach
ja ich danke euch auch sehr fürs
zuschauen wir haben das gesehen es ist
ein zwiespältiges bild eine zwiespältige
gefühlslage dort in großbritannien zum
einen natürlich die tiefe trauer über
den tod von queen elizabeth der zweite
zum anderen ist zeitgleich aber auch die
neue ära von könig charles dem dritten
gestartet der viele aufgaben vor sich
hat der viele herausforderungen hat um
auch die jüngere generation zu
überzeugen mehr zu überzeugen und mehr
zu all diesen themen auch zum
gedenkgottesdienst in support of the
seeker fidel das gibt es jetzt natürlich
auf den kanälen des zdf in der zdf-
heute- app oder auch in einem zdf
spezial jetzt im zweiten wer von uns
hätte er heute live sagen dankeschön
fürs zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal
tschüss